Convention was signed outlawing the slave trade, but...
A ship has just dropped anchor, Great King.
That's fine, that's fine. This ship wouldn't be Portuguese, English, or French.
It's under English colors, Great King.
Very well, very well. And have we any ebony to sell?
Truth to tell, our business has done well lately. Nearly all of our slaves have been sold.
It's not sure. We can supply all they'd like.
Then go to work. What are you waiting for?
Send our hunters out to round up some slaves, and while you're at it, go and capture an entire village.
Yes, and loving is giving to your fellow man.
That is what I learned one day from a wise old man whose skin was as dark as ours.
Why are you telling us this, Father?
Don't all people have dark skin like us?
Oh, no, my child.
Because there are people with light skin.
I hope you never meet one of them.
As our traditional tales say, they're evil.
They sow unhappiness, stay out of their path.
Must clear to have good planting land.
All right.
Somebody shout.
Lisa Monksage says that a chief of a coastal land has sent out warriors to capture us and our neighbors.
All of you be on your guard.
What did we do to them?
Doesn't that mean war?
Why are they doing this to us?
They want to sell us to white men who would make us their slaves.
That's the reason.
But we won't let them do it.
We won't.
We'll outwit them.
And here is what we're going to do.
Right all, they won't go away.
The time has come to use maximum force and this will be our last chance.
Place to get water.
Strongest.
Get a good for a little rest.
Go listen Beth, I'll buy her, say a bag of robber.
It's a large sack of pep, tape, a sack of ivory, how's that?
Those two I will buy then, and that one. How much for the whole set?
No dear, I'm selling him to the white man and he's going to cost them plenty, I guarantee you that.
Go on, bunch of good fun. The more muscle on you, the more you're worth.
I can't go on.
I'll carry her bag? Me, I'm strong, I'll carry it. If you want to, you carry it.
What's that? It's the sea, the ocean.
See? Look how beautiful it is.
And that is my master's palace. He's very rich. Very rich and powerful.
You're going to help him be even richer and more powerful.
Soon it took you long enough.
But capturing all those excellent slaves took more time than...
Did you bring back many?
I got you first-class quality. You'll be pleased. You never saw such quality.
There are how many in total?
Many.
Thought I told you I wanted a whole village. You know what a village is, you village idiot?
Was it how you saw such a tiny village?
I am going to sell you right now to the White, this idiot!
Great Captain, I am the Great Yavogan of our Great King. I come in his name.
Say you are the one.
The Great Yavogan, the Minister of Foreign Trade. If the Captain would care to follow me?
Capitaine Dupandor, subject of His Majesty the King of France. We look alike.
Huh? Yes, we look alike.
We'll permit a few gifts for Your Majesty.
I'll talk business if you want.
You will purchase all you've got of rubber, an ivory, pepper, and especially all the ebony wood you care to sell.
Tell me how many you've got.
Tell me how much you'll pay.
In exchange, I'm offering you a barrel of excellent brandy, cloth, barrels of gunpowder, rifles, shells, strings of pearls, and one or two special gifts.
It's worth a fortune, your majesty, it's worth a fortune.
Now, your majesty, show me your ebony. Five rifles, two barrels of powder.
I'll give you six rifles, three barrels.
Eight rivels, three barrels.
Done.
Laura!
Bolts of cloth plus two barrels of liquor.
I say two bolts of cloth plus three barrels of brandy.
Three bolts of cloth.
I say three bolts and four barrels.
Sure are ugly, they look pale like they're sick.
And they are evil. I hope the Dutchman buys us.
Five!
Plus one.
Where do you think we're going?
I don't know. Maybe to France?
Oh no, my children.
No, we're not going to France, but America.
America? Where in the world is that?
It's far away, it's on the other side of the world.
America yet?
No, no, no, no.
We are going up and down the African coast until the ship is full to breaking.
What do you know about all this anyway?
In my village, I was a wise man, a medicine man.
I was able to foresee many things.
That's funny, but you remind me of somebody, but who?
Now we are off to the Americas.
Pirate, is it you, Pirate?
You knew how him?
Now I lighten me off.
Let's go.
Whim, let's dive over.
No, no lad, no, don't try it. You wouldn't have a chance.
What's going on, sheep?
Siplien, hold and chain him!
Who do you think you are, huh?
It gets cut!
I warn you, my beard has magic powers, you'd better be careful!
If you cut it, you will be cursed!
Yeah, I'm alright, but I'm sure hungry.
Thanks!
Oh, I'm alright, a little seasick, I have to get used to it.
Say, Captain, our cargo's getting weaker.
Oh, that's bad for business, we'll lose money, we have to do something, right?
Uh-huh.
Give them some exercise. That'll do it.
Good idea, Captain, and I know just the sort of exercise that'll be good for 'em.
You, come over here. Come on, play a lively tune.
You bring up all my slaves. Up, go on deck, and quick!
Think we have a chance of getting away?
We outnumber them. In a fight, we'd be sure to come out on top.
Some of our brothers and other ships tried just that,
but just like us, they couldn't sail the white man's ship.
Courage died with them. Did them no good. They perished.
It's a slave ship and it's in mutiny. Take a look.
It's a Dutch one.
A Dutch ship.
Then who cares?
Shipments from Africa are rare?
Yes, only Africans can work well in this hot climate. None of us can.
Yes, and I declare this day is a real scorcher.
Just like that.
In a way, you could say what you're pulling off is a white wasp.
And you could use a freshening up.
I could. I don't look good. Hey, no, what's the point?
No, no, no, believe me, your oil is no good at all.
it's worthless but this one does wonders give it to me right now oh beer what is it about to begin
no unsold goods all goods will be sold in lots naturally no unsold merchandise well it's just
good business what am i dead and even tobacco we tried indians even poor whites but no nothing can
replace a black when it comes to hard work all right who's spinning first bed too old no good
for anything. What? What? You have the merchandise first quality. Come and see. Yeah, these are too
skinny. You can't get any work out of them. 9th lot. 8 high quality slaves. Too many women. No
sale. Lot 22. Superb quality. 3 fine slaves. Who's first? Just a minute. I'm in this lot too.
Where did you come from? Maybe down in the hole. Where do you think? But without Methuselah. I'm
sorry, but the deal is the whole lot on nothing. Gentleman, he needs a second lesser officially for
You'll be second in charge and have a brand new whip, and you can use it all you want.
Please, sir, you have this man. He just got 200 lashes.
If he comes away, hear him ring them bells, and he'll be snagged in the branches.
Child, you'll need all your courage. A few hours ago, they took your little boy away.
What possible interest would I have in them? They're too little to work. Look at them!
Look, you know, now it's illegal to import slaves. I'll sell you these at a good price.
And in a few years, they'll grow up and work hard. You can't go wrong.
Can't go wrong.
It was a shame, taking children from their mothers.
Goodness, I think I know you.
What's your name?
Pierrot.
That I don't charge a lot.
When I think of a little boy, poor Pierrot, my God.
Don't cry, my child.
Don't torment yourself.
I saw Pierrette.
She's with Mokhtar in a beautiful coffee plantation.
They don't work in the fields.
They're servants in the mansion.
And they're well treated.
Children are cared for.
Yours, too.
And they all play together.
You can believe in my visions.
You know that.
I just want to get away from this place.
I want to go before they steal all our children.
But where would we go?
I heard that up north, in those states, there's no slaves.
But can we really trust them?
Let's go up north.
Our children will be free.
Be free.
Things arranged.
So, a little discussion, huh?
Here, you work.
You don't talk.
It will weigh what you say.
For 200 pounds, you'll be punished.
These days, your whip will be turned against you.
You sure you won't go with us?
You won't change your mind?
I'd better stay with the others. I'll do what I can for them, as little as it may be.
You go on north, Third Hope.
Your route will be difficult and dangerous, and even if you make it,
you will continue to suffer and struggle, and that seems to be our fate.
But I know that one day your children will be free and respected.
Who knows, one day even state governors, and even the president.
It required several decades before the slave trade was finally abolished,
and no more slave ships crossed the ocean.
The French went on until 1831,
and slavery wasn't totally abolished in the United States
until after the Civil War.
10 to 14 million people were taken from Africa
and deported to the new world, the Americas.